welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show we're taking your calls at eight
five five two three six 32:28 Brayden in
Las Vegas Nevada you're on the bench
Pierrot she'll go far Braden hey Ben
thanks for having me
you bet go for it sir so I'm a 20 year
olds conservative in college right now
and I wanted to ask you when in the near
future do you think that liberal college
campuses and the liberal population in
America overall will start to shift away
from their flawed philosophies and it's
not assumed what do you think the harm
will be to future generations
if leftist continued to silence the
population and dominate cultures and
even if conservatism
eventually comes hollowed out yeah
Braden this is the real concern
obviously I mean the thing that I'm most
worried about is changing the
constitutional bargains such that there
is no recovery possible obviously as
long as free speech is still available
as long as freedom of religion is still
available as long as social institutions
still remain there's always hope for a
future regrowth of conservatism if you
had asked conservatives back in 1964 and
Barry Goldwater was getting shellacked
whether the country was ever going to
turn to the right again probably people
would have said no and it seems as
though the the ascent of the left was
eternal and and forever and by 1980
Ronald Reagan was president so I'm never
a member of the sort of complete despair
at contingent but at the same time when
you have the left trying to openly
redraw the boundaries of what is allowed
to be said in the United States that's
the part that's scary because if you're
not even allowed to make the argument if
your prosecuted for making the argument
you got a problem I mean Elizabeth
Warren came out this week and suggested
that it should be prosecuted to
distribute disinformation online well
what if she counts what constitutes
disinformation like if I claimed that
Elizabeth Warren was Native American
would that constitute disinformation for
which I could be prosecuted or if I
claimed for example that Medicare for
all would only cost 19 trillion dollars
instead of 33 trillion dollars and then
I was going to get all the money for it
from a wealth tax would that be
disinformation that's prosecutable if
Elizabeth Warren runs the show of course
the answer is no but if I say that
Elizabeth Warren is a damned liar then
presumably I get prosecuted it's the
it's the shutting down of the mechanisms
of debate that frightens me the most and
what the left is doing right now that
any attempt to shut down the ability of
religious people to teach their kids
what they want I think that actually
comes to conflate
I mean that's I think that's the
breaking point I think when you have
states like California that make it
illegal for you to homeschool your kids
and teach them traditional sexual
morality I think at that point so many
people leave the state that the state
completely collapses and or people start
resisting the state and then things get
pretty ugly pretty quickly Braden I
really appreciate the call Jason and
Iowa go for you have a weird question
Jason wondering why you have not had a Z
Osborne on Sunday special well I mean I
think that in order to be on the Sunday
special you have to speak intelligible
English and I'm not sure an hour of ozzy
osbourne saying words that don't appear
to be words I kind of I'll be honest
with you I love crazy train crazy train
is a great song right I mean what his
offense that sting song how the others
warden's a talented guy when he's not
biting the heads off bats but I just I
think that's gonna be kind of a weird
Sunday special Jason appreciate the very
very odd call the Aaron in Alabama
you're on the bench appear oh should I
go for dinner back in college I I had a
question what of president from 100-day
plan has he actually accomplished this
question is not just for me but for my
family and everyone else who wants to
know whether President Trump is actually
doing a good job and it's not a crazy
man as the media portrays it so they're
they're a bunch of different things that
he proposed to accomplish in his first
hundred days and I'm going back and
looking at it now so I don't have it
memorized
so he had proposed a hiring freeze on
all federal employees I don't believe
that that has this happened but he's
reduced federal regulations he is
required that for every new federal
regulation to existing regulations must
be limited I believe he's kept that one
he had proposed a five-year ban on White
House and congressional officials
becoming lobbyists after they leave
government service I don't believe that
that has been effectuated he had
proposed a complete ban on foreign
lobbyists raising money for American
elections I believe he did do that he
announced his intention to renegotiate
NAFTA that was done he announced
withdrawal from the TPP that was done he
directed his secretary of the Treasury
to label China a currency manipulator I
believe he backed off of that one after
looking at it he did allow projects like
the Keystone pipeline to move forward he
talked about canceling money to the UN
climate change programs and I believe he
has done that as well
he has canceled unconstitutional
executive actions by President Obama he
is he is attempted to cancel federal
funding to sanctuary cities although
that has been challenged in court he has
moved toward more removal of criminal
illegal immigrants from the country so
in other words a lot of his plan he
actually did push it didn't do it within
the hundred days but a lot of it he is
pushed and this is one of the reasons
why I'm a lot more saying what about
President Trump that I was about
candidate Trump already coming up we're
gonna bring you the latest on
impeachment could this thing be over as
soon as tomorrow night we'll bring you
the updates this is the Ben Shapiro show